uh fire that started you see it there
that is the reason why
they first
decided to evacuate those specific
sections once they got those sections
moved out onto the concourse level
they then obvious at this time by order
of the fire chief we are being asked to
slowly
and calmly evacuate the building there
is no threat
there is no threat to public safety
i'd like to repeat
there is no threat to public safety
the game has been suspended
and we need to ask you to please
in an orderly and calm manner evacuate
scotiabank arena
so the raptors leading
66-38 you just heard from the public
address announcer he mentioned that the
game is being
suspended i don't know if that means
that everybody's going to be
everyone's going to leave the building
and then at some point be allowed to
come in if they're able to handle
the current situation we will see
let's send it now up to kayla gray
caleb hey thanks matt yeah so obviously
the situation is fluid but right where
we usually sit on the perch on top of us
is where we're assuming that there was a
fire to one of the speakers i actually
was able to talk and get a little bit of
clarification from one of the
firefighters here and the reason why
everyone is asked to evacuate is because
the speaker is in a very particular spot
someone might have to descend to
actually put it out so what they're
worried about is if it continues to get
engulfed it might fall something might
happen someone might be hit
so in terms of why we are evacuating
they just want to make sure that they
are taking all necessary precautions for
safety guys
thank you kayla and
obviously the folks here at the arena
moving out in a very
orderly fashion and obviously as a
precautionary measure right now
the toronto fire department has made the
decision to suspend the game at this
stage
so just talking to
jen quinn appreciate her coming over and
the
we're being told at this time so there
was a small electrical
fire that was in a speaker
and so they were concerned obviously
that the speaker it's one of the reasons
why the pa system was shut down
for a time being they were concerned
that obviously that it could
fall
and so they're now trying to
uh decipher exactly it's suspended now
the game
does that mean
that it's suspended to a later date
later time or
will they play it resume it later later
yeah it's a very fluid situation and
obviously
um
we appreciate everybody just taking
their time
you know getting out it isn't something
as far as
panic and
it's just everyone
do what you're supposed to do they are
you can see the fire
department there
above that section 104106
area and clearly clearly it's a
difficult spot to get to so uh it's
going to take some manpower and some
work
to get up there and assess the situation
directly so uh
all the
in-house security
uh as well as uh obviously the toronto
fire department in the midst of
assessing this right now and so that's
why
they began with that section right the
concern there about that speaker
understandably so
you do see fans making their way
out
onto the concourse level
no i mean some fans still lingering
about obviously with that entire section
is now
essentially empty where they wanted it
to be
empty
and
the toronto raptors obviously
unfortunate
because they got off to such a great
start jack and playing at a very high
level
and so now they're back in the locker
room awaiting word just like we are
indiana also
waiting word just like we are as well
i'd like to say one thing thank god it
happened with 405 remaining in the
second quarter where you have mostly
everybody in their seats and you're able
to make the announcement and get
everyone out in an orderly fashion if
it's at halftime sometimes the lights go
down and it becomes a much more
difficult situation to handle so uh i'm
really impressed
with how great all the fans are in terms
of moving out in an orderly fashion and
uh just trying their best to
assess the situation but
um
everything's calm everything's uh okay
here
and uh right now the raptor's just
trying to uh the official's just trying
to
get things under control here but uh hey
game was exciting rapt has played very
very well to this point and in terms of
the word suspend we don't know yet what
that means i just saw some video footage
via a phone
that someone took of
the speaker so you could see some sparks
there and obviously doing the right
thing
and taking
all the precautions necessary we hope
obviously to be playing basketball again
this evening however
understandable that the precautions
are being taken here we are going to
remain here throughout the course of the
evening until further notice and
hopefully we'll resume basketball
at some point this evening
but as of right now we're going to go to
a commercial break and then we'll come
back right after these words live from
scotia bank arena
ladies and gentlemen once again
i ask that you please
get up from your seats and please
evacuate the building